and we're going to the capitol on
january 6 2021 president donald trump
did not accompany his supporters to the
capitol to disrupt the certification of
his election loss but he wanted to thank
you very much according to cassidy
hutchinson the first former trump white
house employee to testify publicly trump
finished his stop the steel speech
boarded his limousine and was surprised
to learn from his security chief bobby
engel that their destination was the
white house the president said something
to the effect of
i'm the effing president take me up to
the capitol now
to which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr trump then used his free hand to
lunge towards bobby angle and mr when mr
ronato had recounted this story to me he
had motioned towards his clavicles
hutchinson did not see the episode
herself but said she heard it from tony
ornato the former white house chief of
operations and with angle present
the anecdote was the most startling of
many shared by the former white house
aide at tuesday's hearing one that was
urgently announced after the committee
said it received new evidence
police audio from january 6 revealed
guns had been spotted among the crowd
gathered near trump's rally hutchinson
said backstage she heard trump say the
event should not have had metal
detectors i overheard the president say
something to the effect of
you know i don't even care that they
have weapons
they're not here to hurt me the ensuing
violence contributed to the deaths of at
least seven people and injured 150
police officers hutchinson said she
watched the riot unfold from the white
house just doors down from trump she
recounted this conversation between her
boss chief of staff mark meadows and the
white house's top lawyer i remember pat
saying something to the effect of
mark we need to do something more
they're literally calling
for the vice president to be effing hung
and mark had responded something to the
effect of
you heard him pat he thinks mike
deserves it he doesn't think they're
doing anything wrong
the he was trump according to
hutchinson's testimony she said trump
was reluctant when he called off the
rioters more than three hours into the
violence we have to have peace
so go home
we love you you're very special trump
weighed in on tuesday's hearing saying
he hardly knows hutchinson and denied
many of the accusations
hutchinson also says meadows and trump's
former personal attorney rudy giuliani
both sought presidential pardons and she
says many members of trump's inner
circle were concerned that the cabinet
would use the 25th amendment to remove
trump from office committee members say
they've seen concerning signs of witness
tampering but plan at least two more of
these hearings in july
heidi joe castro al jazeera washington